[Musik]
wahl start mit panne bei der abstimmung
der us demokraten in dem die ergebnisse
immer noch nicht fest ein arzt der vor
corona bangte dokumente und zeugen legen
nahe dass chinas führung den ausbruch
des virus vertuschten und einsatz für
emrich an
der prominente neuzugang könnte erstmals
für den bvb spielen heute im pokal gegen
werder bremen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann
für den schwachen schön blöd von mir
us-präsident am kann zufrieden sein bei
den ersten vorwahlen bei denen
republikaner und demokraten ihren
kandidaten für die präsidentschaftswahl
im november küren haben in 97 prozent
seiner republikaner für ihn gestimmt für
seine gegner
die demokraten geriet die auszählung zur
blamage seit stunden ist die partei
nicht in der lage ihre wahlergebnisse zu
veröffentlichen
offenbar hat eine neue app versagt aus
gestratz
es ist ein seltsam anmutendes verfahren
der so genannte cookies auf
parteiversammlungen setzten sich die
wähler in den bereich ihres kandidaten
dann werden die gruppen ausgezählt die
ergebnisse sollten per app durchgegeben
werden doch eine technische panne
verzögert dass ein hacker angriff wird
ausgeschlossen bis heute keine
ergebnisse als ein kandidat willst du
wissen was passiert ist genau wie der
rest amerikas für die freiwilligen der
wahlkampagnen die die letzten wochen so
hart gearbeitet haben tut es mir leid
von kandidat joe biden kein kommentar in
der nacht sein team kritisiert in einem
schreiben erhebliche mängel im prozess
dass vielleicht auch weil es nicht gut
aus für ihn
bereits zuvor hatte der kampf um die
deutungshoheit begonnen so hatte sich
peter judge schon mal zum sieger erklärt
euro war du hast die nation geschockt
allen anzeichen nach werden wir
siegreich weiterreisen
zur nächsten vorfall in new hampshire
wie buddha jobs gibt auch bernie sanders
eigene zahlen heraus auch erklärt sich
zum sieger präsident trump hat für die
vorwahl bei den demokraten nur spott
übrig der korpus der demokraten ist ein
desaster nichts funktioniert genau so
haben sie auch das land geführt
die menschen in rio wahr sie können es
nicht fassen am morgen danach
ich mache mir sehr große sorge wenn wir
das mit dem korb ist hier nicht
hinbekommen wie wird das dann bei der
großen präsidentenwahl eine blamage für
die demokraten eine partei die noch
nicht mal eine vorwahl organisieren kann
und mit ihren jeweiligen sieges
erklärungen setzen die spitzenkandidaten
die glaubwürdigkeit dieser wahl vollends
aufspielen
ein fehlstart zum auftakt eines langen
wahlkampfs am nachmittag ortszeit soll
wohl ein teil der ergebnisse von europa
bekanntgegeben werden
wir werden sie auf dem laufenden halten
wie die komplizierten vor wahlen
funktionieren können sie in unserem
online angebot nachlesen außerdem auf
heute.de wie es weitergeht bis zum
wahltag
wer heute mit einer uniklinik zu tun
hatte dürfte es gemerkt haben viele
ärzte dort waren im warnstreik in
mehreren städten gab es kundgebungen
die ärztegewerkschaft marburger bund
wollte noch einmal druck machen vor der
dritten verhandlungsrunde mit den
ländern
es geht vor allem um bessere
arbeitsbedingungen
die klinikärzte fordern dass
arbeitszeiten zuverlässig erfasst werden
bereitschafts und wochenenddienste
sollen begrenzt werden und das gehalt
soll steigen um 6 prozent oliver deuker
berichtet kaum pausen zunehmender
zeitdruck jede menge überstunden und
bereitschaftsdienste mediziner alltag an
deutschlands universitätskliniken laut
der gewerkschaft marburger bund arbeiten
ärzte dort durchschnittlich 56 stunden
pro woche wenn ich am tag zehn zwölf
stunden arbeitet dann bin ich nicht mehr
fit und meine patienten gut zu versorgen
das glauben die wenigsten von uns heute
streiken und wirklich mehr zu verdienen
darum geht es nicht
sondern wir möchten die patienten gut
versorgen deswegen sind wir ärzte
geworden die arbeitsbelastung so hoch
dass es eigentlich nicht mehr geht es
heißt druck ohne ende das bedeutet im
endeffekt immer weniger kolleginnen und
kollegen kümmern sich um immer mehr
patientinnen und patienten mehr als 3000
ärzte aus ganz deutschland protestierten
deshalb in hannover ein hauptanliegen
eine zuverlässige arbeitszeiterfassung
um die patientenversorgung zu
gewährleisten wird arbeitszeit oftmals
gar nicht erfasst oder es werden zeiten
gekappt es werden stunden nicht
dokumentiert insbesondere beim thema
überstunden stellen wir fest dass da
viel im argen liegt doch die
tarifverhandlungen für die rund 20.000
ärzte an 23 universitätskliniken
bundesweit sind ins stocken geraten
das sind schwierige diskussionen oder
werden wir schauen müssen dass eine gute
lösung finden das muss auch für die
klinikbetreiber leistbar sein und vor
allen dingen müssen wir auch vor dem
hintergrund der tatsache dass wir
ärztemangel haben ausreichend erst zu
für den bereitschaftsdienst haben sie
seit dem frühen nachmittag sitzen die
tarifparteien in einer dritten
verhandlungsrunde wieder zusammen
überstunden werden wohl auch hier
anfallen zum corona virus in deutschland
haben sich zwei weitere menschen
angesteckt beide in bayern aus dem
umfeld der firma webasto bei der die
ersten infizierten registriert wurden
damit gibt es hierzulande zwölf
bestätigte fälle
ganz anders die dimension in china dort
sind mittlerweile mehr als 20.000
menschen infiziert neben täglich neuen
zahlen erreichen uns auch immer wieder
offizielle bilder von neuen
krankenhäusern und motivierten helfern
von vielen betten für die vielen
patienten von akribischer hygiene ja
sogar u bahn stationen werden hier
desinfiziert wo wir nicht hinschauen
sollen haben kamerateams in der regel
keinen zutritt
wie in der am schlimmsten betroffenen
region um wohin unser korrespondent ulf
röller berichtet
wo an seltene nicht zensierte einblicke
in eine abgeriegelte millionenmetropole
bei den wenigen menschen auf der straße
wird die temperatur gemessen
es gibt tanks mit desinfektionsmitteln
die leute kommen und füllen sich ihre
flaschen auf er hat eines der wenigen
offiziellen taxis die fahren dürfen um
kranke zu transportieren wie
desinfizieren jedes mal das auto bevor
wir jemand abholen
die dramatische ausbreitung des virus
hätte wohl verhindert werden können
dr lieben lernen der arzt aus wo hahn
warnte bereits ende dezember nach der
untersuchung von erkrankten vor dem
corona virus die behörden brachten ihn
mit diesem schreiben zum schweigen wenn
sie weiter dickköpfig sind und weiter
sich illegal verhalten werden wir sie
vor gericht zerren
später gab der bürgermeister von johann
zu auf druck von oben den ausbruch
verschwiegen zu haben
ich kann als bürgermeister erst die
informationen bekanntgeben wenn ich die
erlaubnis dazu bekomme erst gut drei
wochen später wurde wo an dicht gemacht
sie will nicht erkannt werden denn sie
erzählt uns dass man lange vorher von
dem virus wusste ich wusste schon vor
einem monat bescheid jemand sprach über
ein corona virus darüber durfte man
nicht reden sonst würde man festgenommen
info an begann die solche die sich jetzt
im ganzen land ausbreitet und nicht nur
dort fragen sie sich warum chinas
machthaber nicht früher handelten zurück
nach deutschland elektroautos sollen
attraktiver werden dafür hatte die
bundesregierung eine kaufprämie von 6000
euro angekündigt im november bezahlt
halbe-halbe vom bund und von den
herstellern klingt erst mal prima kommt
aber nicht in die gänge weil so die
kritik von opposition und experten die
unterlagen erst jetzt bei der eu zur
genehmigung liegen aus berlin daniel
kunz bis zu 6000 euro zuschuss g auto
ein attraktives versprechen
nach dem sogenannten auto gipfel anfang
november verkündet wurde
doch danach passierte wie eine anfrage
der grünen ergab erst mal erstaunlich
wenig das wirtschaftsministerium sandte
der europäischen kommission den
entsprechenden entwurf erst am 20 januar
zur notwendigen prüfung zu ich habe kein
verständnis für die behäbigkeit des
wirtschaftsministers dieses jahres das
entscheidende jahr für die deutsche
automobilindustrie
die hersteller haben neue co2 vorgaben
aus brüssel zu erfüllen das heißt die
fahrzeuge müssen jetzt auf den markt die
dürfen kein ladenhüter werden genau das
passiere aber gerade sagt eine
untersuchung der uni duisburg essen
je nach fahrzeugklasse seien die
verkaufszahlen in den vormonaten um bis
zu 50 prozent eingebrochen
autoverkäufer beklagen zu den jetzigen
alten konditionen wurde niemand kaufen
die leute die jetzt sich interessieren
für ein elektrofahrzeug wollen natürlich
klarheit haben und die können wir im
moment so nicht liefern
die eu muss die prämie prüfen ob sie mit
eu recht vereinbar ist wie lange die
prüfung dauert sei nach wie vor nicht
absehbar so die bundesregierung leider
kann ich jetzt nicht genau kann ich
erzählen mir gesagt wir sind seit ende
des letzten jahres da im gespräch es gab
auch in den vergangenen wochen wieder
wieder gespräche und austausch mit den
zuständigen generaldirektion also die
arbeiten laufen laufen damit hochdruck
erfahrene politiker verfahren zu dass er
zuerst sich klar machen mit ihren
behörden wie prämien umgesetzt werden
und dann bremen ankündigen und nicht
umgekehrt bremen ankündigen und dann
überlegen was man bei der eu alles
machen muss damit die prämien genehmigt
werden es war ein katastrophaler
elementarer handwerklicher fehler der in
berlin das wirtschaftsministerium
da gemacht hat ungewohnt scharfe kritik
aus der wissenschaft nachdem der
erhoffte massive verkaufsanstieg bei
autos vorerst weiter ausbleibt
die weltgesundheitsorganisation warnt am
heutigen weltkrebstag vor einer
möglichen verdoppelung der erkrankungen
gab es 2018 noch 18 millionen
krebskranke rechnet die bhu in 20 jahren
mit bis zu 37 millionen grund seien
unter anderem die schlechte versorgung
in armen ländern aber auch der
lebensstil so sei rauchen für jeden
vierten krebstoten verantwortlich
auch in deutschland bleibt krebs die
zweithäufigste todesursache
doch es gibt erfolgreiche ansätze in der
therapie petra otto berichtet frau
müller und frau merle haben beide einen
tumor in der leber beiden half die chemo
nicht beide wurden genetisch untersucht
erhalten jetzt eine personalisierte
therapie das heißt medikamente die ihre
tumorzellen gezielt angreifen diese
therapie spricht endlich an beiden ich
fühle mich auch gut ich habe keine
nebenwirkungen was sie bei der chemo-
gehabt habe möglichst also relativ
wirklich gut immer besser verstehen die
forscher wo der tumor spuren in der dna
hinterlässt immer aussagekräftiger
werden die bildgebungsverfahren diese
pad computertomographie bilder zeigen
nicht nur wie groß der krebs in der
leber ist man sieht auch dass er
zunächst sehr aktiv und nach der
behandlung fast leblos ist diese
technologien die bislang eigentlich nur
im forschungs zusammenhang zur verfügung
gestanden haben die sind jetzt so weit
entwickelt und auch so preisgünstig dass
wir sie den patienten zur verfügung
stellen können immer mehr technik heißt
immer mehr bilder daten informationen
die sammeln sie hier
auch aus anderen kliniken und lehrern
den computer selbstständig tumoren zu
erkennen
wir sind heute schon so weit dass wir
systeme entwickeln können die
hinweise liefern in einem bild wo eine
pathologien eine krankhafte veränderung
sein könnte wir werden sehen in den
nächsten jahren dass wir diese
ergänzende hilfe stellende art der
nutzung künstlicher intelligenz
zunehmend einsetzen werden im tübinger
zentrum für personalisierte medizin
entwickeln verschiedene fachärzte aus
all diesen bildern und daten persönlich
zugeschnittene therapie eine frau merle
eine für frau miller
in zukunft wird das ganz normal sein als
mutterkirche der reformation ist die
stadtkirche in witten bekannt doch sie
trägt auch ein dunkles erbe eine sau an
deren zitzen juden saugen dazu ein
rabbiner der dem für juden unreinen tier
unter den schwanz schaut so zu sehen in
einem antisemitischen relief an der
fassade der kirche seit jahrzehnten wird
über den umgang mit der sogenannten
[ __ ] gestritten
ein mitglied der jüdischen gemeinde
wollte die abnahme vor gericht
durchsetzen
ohne erfolg felix zimmermann die
stadtkirche in wittenberg seit 700
jahren ist die judenfeindliche plastik
die sogenannte [ __ ] dort angebracht
der zum judentum konvertierte michael
dillmann fühlt sich durch die plastik
beleidigt fordert von der kirche
gerichtlich diese zu entfernen
diese juden zu ist nicht nur geschichte
sie produziert täglich antisemitismus
doch das olg naumburg gab heute der
beklagten kirche recht zwar liege in der
plastik prinzipiell eine beleidigung
aber durch den kontext den die beklagte
der plastik gegeben hat nämlich eine
informationstext und das mahnmal am fuße
der plastik hat sie den beleidigenden
charakter der plastik neutralisiert
wittenberg ist kein einzelfall
an und in zwölf evangelischen und
katholischen kirchen finden sich solche
darstellungen entfernt sollen sie nicht
werden wegen historischer verantwortung
es ist wichtig dass wir die
schrecklichen symbole unserer geschichte
unter fahrradgeschichte wenn ich dazu
sagen nicht einfach unsichtbar machen
nicht einfach nur ins museum stellen
der zentralrat der juden fordert von
allen betroffenen kirchen entweder die
entfernung der plastiken oder einen
kritischen hinweis vor ort denn dass
antisemitismus auch nicht nur aber auch
kirchliche wurzeln hat das wird gerade
an einer solchen stelle ist er deutlich
michael dillmann will nun den
bundesgerichtshof anrufen
die kirchen werden sich damit weiter
rechtlich und moralisch mit ihrem
schwierigen erbe beschäftigen müssen
ich habe eben ein berg unterschlagen es
ging natürlich um die stadtkirche in
wittenberg wegen einer panne im
landeskriminalamt baden württemberg ist
eine krankenschwester zu unrecht
verdächtigt worden babys morphium
verabreicht zu haben
nun ist klar die sichergestellten maut
jungs spuren stammen aus einem
lösungsmittel des lka und nicht aus
einer spritze im spind der angestellten
in der uniklinik ulm
die ermittler gehen weiter davon aus
dass ein unbekannter den fünf frühchen
morphium gegeben hat die unwetter und
der dauerregen haben in süd und
westdeutschland zu ersten
überschwemmungen geführt die mosel ist
an einigen stellen über die ufer
getreten in der nähe von trier wurden
häuser von den wassermassen
eingeschlossen
mehrere keller liefen voll in teilen von
sachsen schneit es seit letzter nacht
immer wieder sehr stark wie hier im
erzgebirge zahlreiche straßen mussten
gesperrt werden
und jetzt fußball dfb-pokal norbert
görder gegen werder bremen gegen dorfen
bvb fans haben da schlechte erinnerungen
ans letzte jahr
da hatte werde auch im achtelfinale die
borussia in dortmund geschlagen heute in
bremen und vielleicht erstmals mit
neuzugang andrew chan sind die
schwarz-gelben klarer favorit
der bvb präsentierte sich zuletzt in
überragender form vor allem die
jungstars um julian brandt berlin holen
und jayden some show verzichten die fans
drei siege in der bundesliga in folge
und jedesmal erzielten die großen fünf
tore eine mannschaft wenn du gewinnst
dreimal nacheinander und so mit vielen
toren es bringt vertrauen natürlich
außerdem könnte er zu seinem debüt in
schwarz gelb kommen neuzugang emrich an
der nationalspieler kam vergangene woche
von juventus turin und ist mit nach
bremen gereist
wir müssen zusammen reden ob er bereit
ist schon im kader zu sein es möglich
ein vor selbstvertrauen strotzende bvb
vielleicht verstärkt mit average ein
das soll auch heute abend in bremen das
rezept seien für die mission
viertelfinale das corona virus hat auch
folgen für die welt des sports china hat
internationale veranstaltungen im
eigenen land abgesagt nachbar japan
verstärkt angesichts der nahenden
olympischen sommerspiele in tokio die
maßnahmen gegen eine ausbreitung des
virus das neue nationalstadion von tokio
gut 68.000 zuschauer werden hier am 24
juli die eröffnung der olympischen
sommerspiele feiern
so ist es geplant und daran soll auch
das corona virus nichts ändern
wie japans premierminister habe
versichert wir werden eng mit der
weltgesundheitsbehörde bh und allen
relevanten organisationen
zusammenarbeiten um negative
auswirkungen auf die vorbereitung der
olympischen spiele und der paralympics
zu vermeiden auswirkungen ganz anderer
art gibt es in china
dort nennt die nationale
anti-doping-agentur china oder den virus
als grund und bis auf weiteres alle
dopingkontrollen auszusetzen
zum schutz der gesundheit von sportlern
und kontrolleuren wie die chinesen
offiziell mitteilt das war schon von mir
heute nacht schneit es noch in den alpen
und im erzgebirge danach wird es
deutlich ruhiger beim wetter die details
hat gleich katja hornuf um viertel vor
zehn begrüßt 10 marietta slomka im heute
journal
wir wünschen ihnen noch einen schönen
abend danken für ihr interesse und sagen
tschüss bis morgen
[Musik]
er nahm meine damen und herren eine so
scharfe wolken grenze wie die hier mit
dem orkantief petra sehen wir wirklich
selten dieser wolken klecks ist jetzt
aber nach osten abgezogen was bei uns
übrig blieb das waren kräftige
regenschauer schneeschauer und zum teil
sogar graupel gewitter und schnee fällt
jetzt auch noch in der nacht vor allen
dingen hier am erzgebirge und auch am
alpenrand da können durchaus so 20 bis
25 cm zusammenkommen und da es im osten
auch noch stürmisch weht drohen vor
allen dingen im erzgebirge auch noch
schneeverwehungen
der kräftige wind macht sich auch an der
ostsee bemerkbar
dort droht ein sturm hochwasser und es
wird glatt auf den straßen selbst wenn
kein schnee fällt da reicht es wenn die
straßen ein bisschen feucht glitzern
denn die temperaturen sinken überall auf
kritische werte zwischen plus 3 und
minus vier grad morgen über tag steigen
sie dann auf null grad über schnee an
den alpen und 9 grad an der nordsee
vormittags schneit es noch ein bisschen
vor allem in sachsen und in bayern dann
aber gibt es überall sehr freundliches
wetter sonne und wolken wechseln sich ab
bei einem nicht mehr so starken wind aus
nordwestlichen richtungen und in den
nächsten tagen geht es deutlich ruhiger
weiter
dabei gibt es die meiste sonne zunächst
im westen schönen abend noch